Speaker 1: Well, it's so great to start with.
Some good news today. Raphael Warnock has
defeated Herschel Walker in the Georgia Senate
runoff. This means that Democrats will control
the Senate 51 to 49 rather than 5050. This has a
number of important consequences, which we are,
of course, going to talk about. But the
big news is that it did not go the way of
Donald Trump and of MAGA and of the Herschel
Walker endorsement industrial complex wing
of the Republican Party. Georgia Senate Runoff
Election Results. Warnock 51.4. Walker 48.6. Now,
I am with everybody in the audience in particular,
many of our viewers from around the world who look
at Herschel Walker and they say, how does
this guy even have a shot in a state like
Georgia with a population voting population in the
millions, how does this guy not lose by 70? Even
as deranged and ignorant as the Republican Party
electorate is in the United States? And of course,
that horrifies me as well. This is a guy who
shouldn't even have had a shot, and yet he
came within under 100,000 votes in the runoff of
becoming one of 100 senators in the United States.
We're not going to fix the United States in that
sense right here in this segment. So I won't dwell
on that too, too much. Democratic Senator
Warnock Wins Georgia Runoff Against Walker,
reports the Associated Press. And indeed now
control of the Senate will be not only excuse me,
I'm almost back from COVID, but not 100%. It
will be not 5050, but it will be 51 to 49. And
there are so many reasons that that is hugely
important, which I will get to. But first,
let's look at a couple of clips. Here are
the calls from the three major networks.
Speaker 2: What does this look like statewide?
Well, I'll let you take it from there, because
I think there's some news there that Chuck.
Speaker 3: Mark is a consequential thing.
NBC News can now project that the winner of
the Georgia U.S. Senate election tonight is
incumbent Democrat Raphael Warnock
cratic governor. We have seen changes
all over senator yet. We're to interrupt
you. I want to go to Jake for a moment.
Speaker 2: Excellence, right. We can now make a
projection in the final Senate election of the
2022 midterm elections. CNN projects Democratic
Senator Raphael Warnock will win reelection in
the Georgia Senate runoff. Right now, we're
relying on the Associated Press to give us
these numbers. And right now, the Associated
Press is just given the check mark to Raphael
Warnock is going back to the US Senate as the
winner of this runoff against Herschel Walker.
Speaker 1: Now we will get back to that Fox
News call because it actually happened at
sort of a very, very interesting moment.
Now, we did hear from both candidates,
winner and loser alike, starting with the
winner, Raphael Warnock. Take a quick listen.
Speaker 4: And after a hard fought campaign.
Or should I say campaigns?
It is my honor. Two out of the four most
powerful words ever spoken. In a democracy,
the people have spoken.
Speaker 1:
Very much so. And Raphael Warnock actually talking
about a number of important points, including the
fact that just because he won doesn't mean there
weren't efforts at voter suppression, which,
by the way, is very different than saying it was
rigged. I know there were some Republicans seizing
on this and saying, look, Republicans aren't
the only ones who say it was rigged. That's
not what Warnock is saying. There are those who.
Speaker 4: Would look at the outcome of this race
and say that there's no
voter suppression in Georgia.
Let me be clear. Just because people endured long
lines that wrapped around buildings some blocks
long, just because they endured the rain and the
cold and all kinds of tricks in order to vote
doesn't mean that voter suppression does not
exist. It simply means that you, the people, have
decided that your voices will not be silenced.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And of course, there were
attempts to suppress the vote. And we
know what these are. Georgia's epicenter
of these try to reduce early voting. They
did this when it came to the period after
Thanksgiving. We covered it on the
award winning bonus show. Of course.
Speaker 4: A bonus show where you want to make
money and everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is.
Speaker 2: Bad.
Speaker 1: Now, we also heard from
the loser who was Herschel Walker,
and there was a question as to whether Herschel
Walker would have any idea what's even going on,
like how does he even give a concession speech?
And he sort of did. And he said something about
the numbers aren't adding up for him.
Speaker 4: We've had a tough journey,
have we not know? One of the things I said
is when they call the race as it enormous,
doesn't look like they're going to add up. Right.
But one of the things I want to encourage you,
because you never stop dreaming. I don't want
any use of dream and I don't want any you to stop
believing in America. I want you to believe in
America. I continue to believe in the Constitution
and believe in our elected officials most of all.
Speaker 1: Well, that belief is slightly
reinforced by the fact that this guy,
fortunately, is not going to be a U.S. senator.
Speaker 4: I continue to pray for
them because of all the prayers you
give me. I felt those players I want to thank.
Speaker 1: Apparently they were not quite enough.
Speaker 4: For my team as well. Our team,
Herschel, because they put up with a lot
and I want to thank Team Herschel. Thank all my
donors as well because you guys, with all you
have, couldn't have done what I've done.
Speaker 1: Yep. So a sort of concession
speech from Herschel Walker. And then maybe
the most important point reminding himself
he's still sort of a winner right there.
Speaker 4: Remember when we all winners.
So we are winners and that's what I want to say.
Well, winners and I always say God is a good God.
Speaker 1: Yep. Everybody won. At the end of
the day, everybody won. At the end of the day.
Donald Trump's reaction, not pleased tweeting in
the tweeting troth thing, of course, on truth,
social censure. Our country is in big trouble.
What a mess. Now, the importance of 5149 rather
than 5050, because either way, it would be a
Democratic majority, because Kamala Harris in
a 5050 tie is the tie breaking vote. And she still
would be the tie breaking vote if there is a 5050
tie in the Senate. But 5149 means Democrats don't
have to negotiate a power sharing arrangement with
the Senate minority leader, Mitch McConnell.
That's a great thing. Number two, there's no
one senator veto power. Okay? Now it's two. So at
5050, Joe Manchin alone or Kirsten cinema alone
becomes sort of one senator veto horse. Now
there is no one senator veto power. It's two,
but that's still a better situation. Committees
is the third issue because of the current power
sharing agreement with the equal Senate split,
any tie on a committee goes to a full Senate
vote. Now Democrats still have the majority, but
if you have a committee with 16 members and you
have an eight and eight split and you have
an 8 to 8 vote, that committee vote now has
to go to the full Senate, where if it's 5050
income's Kamala Harris and breaks the tie,
it's just going to be much faster because having
a majority on the committees, more than likely
Democrats will have a one seat majority on
every committee. You skip that entire dog
and pony show. Still, it's a majority either way,
but it would be much more annoying with the 5050
and it just makes everything faster. And then
also the subpoena issuing process will be much
stronger because you won't really need bipartisan
support to issue subpoenas. That's important. And
if there were to be a Supreme Court vacancy, we
don't know. We'd all wait. You just don't know.
Depends on who who's the nominee and what's
the process, when does it happen? But it's
always better to have more seats in the event that
there is a Supreme Court vacancy or even another
potential judicial vacancy. So very important
MAGA in shambles. And we will talk about that.
But first, let's talk about Laura Ingraham on
Fox News who had a really bad night last night.